this episode is made possible by the
realistic online game war thunder check
out this game through the link in the
description below go through your link
and you not only support this show which
is cool
you get a free premium tank or aircraft
and three days of premium time as a
bonus just before we get into it as well
I do want to say that there's gonna be
some tricky pronunciations in here I'm
looking them up when I can and doing my
best if you're not gonna like it and
it's gonna trigger you or something you
don't have to watch it's cool let's get
into it the art of war is of vital
importance to the state it is a matter
of life and death a road either to
safety or to ruin hence it is a subject
of inquiry which can on no account be
neglected these are the first sentences
of the Sun Zhi Bing far known in the
West as the art of war one of the oldest
treatises on strategy and warfare and
for sure the most quoted around the
globe it's 13 chapters off a high-level
strategic advice to rulers and Generals
focusing on a series of key principles
which should always be kept in mind lest
one takes the road to ruin some of its
commandments are very specific to
warfare in the ancient world for example
chapter 12 is entirely dedicated to
attack by fire but most of its teachings
they can be extrapolated to a variety of
situations outside of the military
environment including politics finance
marketing and even sports what do we
know about its author the legendary Sun
Tzu also known as Sun Z well really
surprisingly little especially for a man
who had such an enduring influence on
the politics and history of China at
first and then the whole world but in
today's biographic Sui attempts to clear
up at least some of the mist that
shrouds the life of master Sun
[Music]
to fully understand the man's son and
the profound legacy of his work we first
need to look at the historical context
in which they appeared the years between
770 BC and 476 BC are known as the
spring and autumn period of China for
these three centuries the land was ruled
by the Java dynasty the Java supplied a
feudal like system with large swaths of
land being administered by local Lords
if a disagreements broke out the Lords
would settle them by means of
small-scale military engagements waged
during bronze weapons and riding on top
of richly decorated chariots these
battles which actually more like large
duels were regulated by a code of honor
and valor based on the philosophy of
Confucianism which values strict
adherence to a system of traditions and
social rules here's a great example as
narrated by historian Robert Griffiths
in ancient China war had been regarded
as a Knightly contest as such it had
been governed by a code twitch both
sides generally at kit many
illustrations of this are found for
example in 632 BC the Qin commands are
after defeating Truett chang puhe gave
the vanquished enemy three days supply
of food this courtesy was later
reciprocated by a true army victorious
at Pea the chivalrous approach to war
was made possible by the small size of
the armies and the low stakes at play
but the round Innis tea was on the
decline until they were finally removed
from power and things while they changed
for the worse a vacuum at the top
normally causes the emergence of
regional powers who are all vying for
supremacy and this is what happened in
China during the so-called period of the
warring States seven main kingdoms Jin
Chu chin kee way you and Wu alongside
their vassal states were at war for much
of the sixth and fifth centuries BC
think Westeros after King Robert's death
or Westeros after King you get the idea
obviously this constant state of
conflict had a massive impact on society
the rulers of the Seven Kingdoms could
not afford to go to war on fancy bronze
chariots but most of all they couldn't
afford to lose and so bronze weapons
they were replaced by iron which is
cheaper and deadlier chariots they were
discarded in favour of cavalry and
infantry units the Warriors are
mr. Kratz and Hiro's he rode into battle
during the spring and autumn gave way to
large armies of conscripts numbering in
the tens and even hundreds of thousands
and large numbers of well-equipped
well-fed men they required tons of money
you're gonna pay for it all well of
course as usual I would be the peasants
the merchants the ordinary folk who were
hard-hit by taxation that depleted the
lands and so descent the kings of the
warring States needed some expert advice
not only on how to overcome their foes
but how to do it efficiently and quickly
but who could provide that advice
sun-woo later known as Sun Tzu or master
Sun was born in 544 BC in the northern
state of Qi in the modern-day province
of Shandong but please don't take this
date too seriously the exact century in
which the master lived is disputed let
alone the exact year but let's just
settle for five hundred forty-four for
the sake of this video
he was obviously literate and he knew a
couple of things about war and
leadership and he traveled across the
warring States which leads us to infer
that he was a sheer horror member of the
landless aristocracy the shares were
traditionally travelling academics but
some woo was more likely a traveling
mercenary it was this particular trade
that took him to travel from his birth
state of Qi to the southern kingdom of
Wu sometime around 510 BC the state of
Wu was at that time sort of underdog in
the Chinese Game of Thrones if you will
this kingdom is located in what is now
the Shanghai province and back at that
time it was smaller and less populated
than its rivals especially the large
neighboring state of Chu that is why the
ruler King Helu was looking for a
top-notch military adviser to organize
and lead his army in war according to
some accounts that this staged master
son had already written the art of war
leading to he Liu to summon him to his
court according to others son was only a
low ranking officer in Hailey's army at
this point but his skills in
unconventional tactics such as ambushes
espionage and counter espionage as well
as surprise attacks on enemy camps had
raised the attention of the king but
what everybody agrees on is how he got
the general job King Helu
challenged son Wu to demonstrate his
military skills by organizing some war
maneuvers not with the soldiers but
rather with court concubines son we
accepted the challenge on two conditions
no interference from the king and
absolute obedience from the concubines
son then proceeded to create two
platoons of 70 or 80 concubines each
appointing as platoon leaders the two
favorites of the king he then instructed
the concubines on how to perform a
series of marching orders in
coordination with the drumbeat but when
the drum sounded the to bleed concubines
burst out laughing and the two platoons
did not obey the orders then some we was
pretty much like well that's cool you
know if they don't obey me the first
time that's generally the generals fault
you know I wasn't clear
enough therefore son gave marching
orders to the concubines again this time
making it very simple and clear what
they had to do and again the drums went
off and again the two favorites just
couldn't stop giggling so at this point
son we commented that he the general had
done his duty and it was now the fault
of the officers if they were not
executing the orders to show that he
meant business he ordered two guardsmen
armed with axes to apprehend the two
concubines he Lou watching at a distance
with his court dispatched a message
asking him to stop please son we do not
chop these ladies heads off my life
would be less fun without them is what
we will assume the note set to which
master son replied that when a general
is in charge his orders must be carried
out the Axman they decapitated the two
squad leaders the deputy lead concubines
were put in charge of the platoons and
soon the maneuvers were carried out
perfectly I've seen that the general
threat of decapitation is a pretty
powerful incentive who knew so in the
end King he knew he wasn't too upset
about all of this and basically he
appointed master son as his lead general
of the army okay now there's a couple of
points we need to get to here number one
we all have a lot to learn from master
son and his book but I would not take
his advice when it comes to job
interviews chopping off the head of the
CEOs and life partner will not get you
your dream job point number two
I personally find it a bit difficult to
believe that this is a true story and
tenth century scholar you Cheng si
agrees it sounds more like a bit of a
parable to illustrate some key lessons
which appear again and again in the art
of war
what are these lessons well there's
absolute obedience of the officers to
the generals discipline coordination
among ranks independence from the
military from political power in wartime
these are the values that make an army
of men into an army of heroes now just
before we get on with the rest of
today's video I do want to take a moment
to tell you about today's rather
appropriate sponsor war funder who make
these long videos possible
warthunder is a realistic free-to-play
military vehicle combat game war
Thunderer's available on PC ps4 and Xbox
one you don't need all of those just one
of them though and there's also no need
to purchase you can just download the
game and play in this game there are
over 1200 historically accurate vehicles
all the way from the 1920s to the 1990s
so no bronze chariots unfortunately but
some more modern and effective stuff all
of these vehicles are carefully built
and incredibly detailed and all of the
physics has really been sweated over so
it's all very very good and look you can
just jump in for a quick arcade game
which is useful if you don't have much
time or you can play realistic for some
more challenging stuff all there's
always simulator mode if you like
getting your ass whipped so join us on
the battlefield for free using the link
below doing that help support this show
which is cool and it also gets you a
free premium tank or aircraft and three
days of premium time as a bonus just for
registering let's get back to it shall
we
[Music]
so what exactly was so revolutionary
about Sun Tzu's approach to warfare his
main contribution was to apply Taoist
principles to the conduct of military
campaigns
unlike the adherents do tradition
supported by Confucianism Daoism
emphasizes adaptability to the natural
flow of things
moreover the DAO chi cheng reflects a
horror of war and a yearning for peace
by combining these two principles you
obtain the foundation of Sun Tzu's
military doctrine follow the natural
path to victory rather than adhering to
contemporary conventional wisdom if
possible avoid war the greatest victory
lies in defeating the enemy even before
a war has begun bus if a war begins the
best way to achieve peace is through a
swift victory these precepts of Sun
Tzu's were soon put to the test in one
of the many conflicts opposing the
kingdoms of Wu and true at the decisive
battle of Beau jeu Sun Tzu is said to
have led through forces along with King
he lose brother Phu guy and defeated the
numerically superior Chu army through
his use of tactics in the art of war Sun
C writes there according to my estimate
the soldiers of true exceed our own in
number that shall advantaged them
nothing in the matter of victory I say
then that victory can be achieved though
the enemy be stronger in numbers we may
prevent him from fighting in other words
take the initiative attack first attack
fast attack where the enemy is weak and
prevents him from concentrating his
forces this is exactly what happened at
Beau jeu despite he lose protestations
fuga Knight listened to Sun Tzu's advice
and challenged the Chu army they
defeated them in a series of five
further engagements which culminated
with the capture of the enemy capital of
yin Phu guys success and the Wu Chi wars
was due to his own courage and his
belief in the precepts of some suit
first he collected intelligence brought
by spies through which he learns that
the opposing general nan hua was
despised by his troops and that they had
no well to fight second he refused to
adhere to the standard rules of war as
understood to that time he did not let
the enemy retreat to safety he attacked
them while they were crossing the
Chingford River prevented their
formation of lines and even later
attacked them while they ate their
dinner so you might have noticed
something about this counter of the
Battle of Bhoja and there's the
was led by fou guy with son su almost
being a shadow in the background is it's
rather interesting to note that we have
these precise historical records of
other generals at King he news court but
nothing so precise about master sang-woo
himself he may have been in fact that
master son who was exactly that omit
phantom and embodiment of a set of
values rather than a real person or if
we wanted to stay more grounded master
son may have been a composite character
the results of different historical
figures merged into one by inaccurate
historical records or an oral tradition
two characters could plausibly be at the
origin of the legend of son su wu zhu
zhu and son bing worzic suit was born
sometime at the ends of the 6th century
and was the son of a nobleman called Wu
Shi from the state of Chu when will she
was executed for an alleged crime wu-six
who fled Shu and after wandering through
the warring States he finally came to
woo here he became acquainted with one
prince Guang to whom he suggested
usurping the throne grande killed the
rightful king Liao and became now good
friends King Helu husak su became he
lose chief advisor so that checks the
advisor to the king box of son su wu
zixu then took advantage of his position
of power to take revenge for the unjust
death of his father and he led a
campaign against the state of Chu and
conquered the rival state in 506 and
this checks the second potential son Zhu
box and that's of course conquering the
capsule of Chu for his military success
he was rewarded with the territory of
Shen but with he lose death his fortunes
they started to decline
ruzek su did not see eye to eye with the
new King footjam who after defeating the
state of you and Qi wanted to go for the
full hegemony of the whole of China well
he takes you advised against that as he
was aware of the limited power of the
kingdom of Woon eventually King Farouk a
favored another general bopi over him
slandered by the new favorite wu zixu
accepted a sword presented by the king
which he used to kill himself in the
year 484 BC
son been known also as son Peng was
rumored in life to be a descendants of
the legendary son soon he lived between
the years of 380 and 316 BC in the state
of Wei he studied military leadership
under two great generals of the period
pang Quan and master queasy but the old
teacher pang Wan became envious of his
pupils and he slandered his reputation
this was quite common at the time it
seems and always had dire consequences
the king of Wei punished son bin by
cutting off his kneecaps the word bin in
fact was not a part of his name at birth
it rather indicates this type of
punishments and was a nickname given to
him in later life somehow son Ben
managed to escape to the northern state
of Qi where he was hired as a general
and led successful campaigns against way
his preferred tactics are a close match
with some of those found in the art of
war such as encircling the enemy forces
and attacking the weaker enemy
formations which requires more support
from other units after his successes
with Qi he retired to the state of true
where he probably died what makes him a
candidate to be the real-life Sun Tzu or
at least one of the characters that
inspired his legend is that son Ben
offered his own art of war the book
titled the art of warfare by son bin was
discovered by archaeologists in 1972 and
it reads like an expansion to the
original book which is attributed to Sun
Tzu whatever the truth about the
identity or existence of master Sun Wu
the man's life will always be secondary
to his greatest achievement a short book
in 13 brief chapters which can be read
in little more than an hour and yet is
charged with a relevance that has
spanned centuries
[Music]
what we know for certain about this book
is that it was first written in the 5th
century BC and later amended in the 2nd
century BC it later spread to most of
East Asia gaining notoriety especially
in Japan around the 8th century AD we
know of at least one Japanese warlord
who used it as an emblem for the four
Chinese characters of wind forest fire
and mountain which represent a famous
maxim from Sun Tzu's work strike like
the wind be as tranquil as a forest be
as devastating as a fire and just firm
as a mountain the book was finally
formalized in its current version in the
11th century AD but we had to wait until
1772 for it to be introduced to the west
thanks to a translation by a french
jesuit priest
the art of war rests on a few key
principles some of which we've already
hinted at the main points which is a
stern piece of advice to all rulers is
that war should not be taken lightly it
is a matter of life and death for the
state and the people living within it at
the very least it should be avoided at
all costs and if this is not possible it
should be extensively planned and
prepared and concluded as swiftly as
possible no state ever benefited from a
prolonged state of war if you want to
know more about Sun Tzu's philosophy of
warfare I strongly encourage you to go
and read the book you can read it or
listen to it for free but a lot of
places online but if you can't spare an
hour your precious time gonna do
something a bit different for this
channel now I thought it would be good
to summarize it because well it's really
really good stuff and you can't do a
biographical out sunsoo and not have
some stuff about the other wars so let's
get into it
chapter 1 dining the 5 key factors of
war a strategy where the terrain
leadership and management's by
considering these factors and comparing
them to the enemy a commander can
calculate chances for victory
chapter 2 waging war or the economy of
warfare success lies in the ability to
win quickly and effectively thus
limiting the cost of military campaigns
chapter 3 strategic attack in which the
master tells us that the strength comes
from unity not size chapter 4
disposition of the army obvious but true
is about the importance of being able to
recognize strategic opportunities and to
not create opportunities for the enemy
chapter 5 forces this is about using
creativity and
timing to build up your armies momentum
chapter six weaknesses and strengths
this is Taoism at its best always adapt
your tactics to changes in the
environment chapter seven military
maneuvers this is about the dangers of
direct conflicts and how to win if you
cannot avoid it it suggests using
initiative to impose your own will on
the enemy and fight under your own
conditions chapter eight variations and
adaptability this is sort of a Taoism
second round adapt your tactics to the
enemy armies responses chapter nine
movements and developments of troops or
how to evaluate the intentions of the
enemy while moving across their
territory chapter 10 terrain and eleven
the nine battlegrounds both of these
chapters discuss how to interact with
different types of grounds to your
advantage at strategic and tactical
levels for example at the strategic
level if positioned at an intersection
between two or more factions or States
always seek an alliance with at least
one of them and a tactical example when
encountering high grounds either occupy
first and hold it and if you can't avoid
it at any cost
chapter 12 attacked by fire there are
five ways to do so burn the soldiers
burn their stores burn their baggage
trains burn their Arsenal's shoot fire
missiles from the distance chapter 13
espionage there are five types of spies
locals spying on the enemy infiltrated
spies double agents spies sowing false
intelligence on purpose and surviving
spies basically those who make it alive
back to your camp for knowledge and
deception are key to the conduct of war
in fact one of the most quoted Maxim's
of Master Sons is exactly that it goes
all war is based on deception
so I really hope you found their video
interesting hopefully you learned a
little bit about ancient Chinese history
and the men who may or may not be Sun
soup if you're less interested about the
author and more interested in the book
let us know in the comments below if
people are into it we'll make a video
about the art of war probably do a top
10 about it on my other channel called
top tens which I will link to below let
us know in the comments if it's if
you're into it we'll do something like
that and as always I really hope you
enjoyed this video please don't forget
to check out our fantastic sponsor war
thunder and as always I'll see you next
time
you
[Music]